Mabuhay! Thank you for choosing Philippine Airlines, Asia's first airline.
Before settling down, please put your bags in the overhead compartment...
...or under the seat in front of you.
Don't stand on your seat.
Seats are for sitting, remember?
To put your bags in the overhead compartment,...
...please use the step board beside your seat.
It's okay, sit back and relax.
We're just going to show you a few things...
...that will make your flight a safe and comfortable travel experience.
Now, take the time to check the safety card in front of you.
Excellent!
You'll notice that the card is full of interesting pictures and instructions.
These are designed to help you better understand the aircraft safety features,...
...so in case of an emergency, you'll know what to do.
About your seatbelt, it may look simple.
But in case we experience turbulence, this will keep you safe and free from harm.
Simply insert the metal end into the buckle until you hear a click.
And pull the loose end to tighten it.
To open, lift top of the buckle.
It is Philippine Airlines' policy that you should always fasten your seatbelt whenever seated.